if you haven't seen Star Wars yet turn
back now here be spoilers I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update JJ
Abrams has admitted that he might have
made a mistake in the latest Star Wars
film while promoting his new thriller 10
Cloverfield Lane he was asked by slash
film about a moment that occurs towards
the end of the force awakens ray
Chewbacca and other resistance fighters
have returned from their mission to
destroy Starkiller base an operation
that has cost Han Solo his life ray is
given a comforting hug by layer while
Paul Chewbacca receives no such sympathy
despite the history that Leia Han and
Chewie have that was probably one of the
mistakes I made Abrams admits my
thinking at the time was the Chewbacca
despite the pain he was feeling was
focused on trying to save Finn and
getting him taken care of so I tried to
have Chewbacca go off with him and focus
on ray and then have ray find layer and
layer find ray had you back had not been
where he was you probably wouldn't have
thought of it but because he was right
there passed by Leia it felt almost like
a slight which was definitely not the
intention last week it was confirmed
that the force awakens would be
available in home video form from Disney
movies anywhere on April first before
hitting blu-ray and DVD on april fifth
do you think Leia should have hugged
Chewie thank chu he was fine and Ray
needed the hug more let me know in the
comments all come and find me on Twitter
I'm at how not to draw thanks for
watching for your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot